bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
sur lcp public sénat votre rendez-vous
45 minutes d'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec michael annett
bonjour katia et les temps forts cette
semaine la peur de manuel valls devant
la percée annoncée du front national
pour le premier tour des élections
départementales nouveau nom des
cantonales premier tour le 22 mars le ps
pourrait connaître une défaite
historique et espère une valve ou
appelez ça une révolution de palais le
changement est en marche au palais du
luxembourg
le sénat a dévoilé ces mesures pour
réformer l'institution attend parole du
coup des sanctions financières pour les
absentéistes des mesures qui ne sont pas
cosmétiques a dit gérard larcher
et puis retour sur une loi emblématique
les 35 heures décidée par le
gouvernement jospin est porté par
martine aubry
un documentaire diffusé sur notre
antenne revient sur l'élaboration de
cette loi
c'était en 1997 sujet toujours
d'actualité on en parlait avec notre
invité est notre invité au vous
présenter tout de suite roger karoutchi
bonjour bonjour sénateur ump des
hauts-de-seine vous avez participé
largement cette semaine à l'actualité
parlementaire du sénat parce que vous
êtes l'un des auteurs du rapport qui
modifient largement le travail
parlementaire au sénat ou en parler bien
évidemment vous connaissez le principe
de l'émission on va écouter quelques
parlementaires qui dresse votre portrait
aulas et vous réagirez juste après
monsieur karoutchi critique sera blâmé
c'est un type entier
qui exprime ses convictions et nous
sommes très souvent d'accord sur les
lignes du gaullisme éternelle sur le
plan de l'idéologie je préférais le
républicain qui était aux côtés de
philippe séguin qui défendaient des
valeurs dans lesquelles je pouvais me
reconnaître et - le roger karoutchi
sarkozyste parce que je pense que
nicolas sarkozy et philippe séguin même
s'ils ont travaillé ensemble un temps
était aux antipodes de ce que peut être
la droite moi j'aime bien roger
karoutchi
c'est quelqu'un avec qui on a bien
travaillé quand il était ministre
notamment chargé des relations avec le
parlement
donc quelqu'un de raisonnable
d'agréables qui a de l'humour plutôt
flatteur gaulliste éternel ça existe
encore pourquoi ça n'existerait plus il
ya bien encore des communistes des
socialistes est bien des notions dont on
se demande à quoi servent pour le pays
oui ça existe encore bien sûr il faut
pas rester dans la nostalgie et
l'historienne je suis ne passe pas son
temps à ouvrir les mémoires mais il ya
des valeurs sûres l'état sur la nation
sur la république qui sont là il faut
pas brandir chaque fois la croix de
lorraine et même si je me rends à
colombes et de manière régulière par
souvenir mais non louis il ya des
valeurs sûres les tailles sur la
république que tu es celle qu'avait
défendues notamment philippe c1 qui sont
des valeurs constantes dans notre monde
politique oui roger karoutchi je vous
propose d déroulées la semaine lundi les
réactions en chaîne après les mots du
1er mai liste sur le front national le
mot
la montée du front national et donc un
sujet au coeur des meetings politiques à
droite comme à gauche et manuel valls a
décidé de dramatiser l'enjeu de ces
élections départementales en évoquant sa
peur regardez ce sujet d'elisa berthelot
et le premier ministre se défend de tout
calcul politicien en meeting de soutien
pour les départementales dans l'oise il
persiste et signe
certains se demandent si en effet on en
parle en je ne fais pas le jeu je mets
des guillemets du front national si même
je ne le met pas au centre du débat
curieux débat enfin l'extrême droite
elle est déjà au centre du débat à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de là
haut tu resteras des autres meetings
nicolas sarkozy est venu soutenir les
candidats de droite dans le val de marne
une réunion publique qui lui permet de
décocher ses flèches à l'encontre du
premier ministre
il faut qu'on s'arrête un moment sur le
cas de notre premier ministre
il va pas pouvoir continuer comme ça
à perdre ses nerfs tous les jours une
aisance et une 7 vient genot un duel à
distance qui fait le bonheur du front
national les prises de positions de
manuel valls sont moqués jusqu'à la tête
du parti
je pense qu'ils ne se maîtrisent plus je
pense qu'en ce moment lui confierait
même pas les clés de sa voiture s'ils
voulaient paraît tellement excité et
nerveux angoissés
je pense que ça n'est plus réfléchi je
pense qu'il a perdu les pédales faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
pour ces départementale manuel valls a
décidé de clairement s'engager mais en
axant leur campagne sur le front
national ps et ump ont réussi à faire du
parti de marine le pen
l'acteur principal de ces élections
voilà alors les mots de manuel valls on
s'est trop commenter la peur la peur que
la france se fracasse sur le fn est ce
que pour vous il a raison de compter sur
ce registre est ce que c'est une
stratégie ou une manoeuvre techno c'est
une manoeuvre
c'est un excellent acteur un joueur et
je pense qu'il se dit voilà comme ils
pensent que le ps va prendre une
dérouillée historique après la
dérouillée des municipales de mars 2014
ils vont perdre 25 départements c'est
comme ça la vie
et comme ils vont perdre largement il se
dit que pour le soir du premier tour du
deuxième tour il préfère que les
commentateurs soit sur les 80 sièges fn
de conseillers généraux même si le fn ne
parvient à prendre aucun département et
c'est plus facile pour lui de faire en
sorte que le commentaire ce soit il ya
80 conseillers généraux le fait que sur
le fait de dire l'ump lune et y ont pris
25 départements à la gauche sous-entendu
cette gauche qui décidément n'y arrive
pas et prend des 30 électorale de mois
en mois chaque fois au jeu voilà roger
karoutchi zeppelin pression aussi que
manuel valls veut une sorte de
bipolarisation entre le parti socialiste
et le front national vous n'êtes plus
sur la photo fut un pardon de vous dire
que s'il ya quelqu'un qui n'est plus sur
la photo c'est le parti socialiste parce
que bon quand vous aurez le premier tour
ouais bon ça c'est réglé
enfin attendez ça suffit ils mettent
même plus les candidats socialistes
mettent même plus le logo ps sur les
affiches pratiquement nulle part
pourquoi parce qu'il se dit si je mets
le logo ps alors là je me bats deuxième
tour donc ils savent bien qu'ils vont
vers une déculottée électorale
il voit les sondages il voit le
discrédit il voit la rechute du couple
exécutif après une embellie en janvier
et ils se disent il faut qu'on trouve
quelque chose
franchement là ça rend pas service au
pays ça rend pas service à la démocratie
et je trouve que ça entrer dans les
détails
manuel valls ferait mieux de se
concentrer sur la gestion des affaires
de la france sur la lutte contre le
chômage sur la lutte contre la fiscalité
excessive sur l' équilibre territorial
mais plutôt que de se lancer dans une
campagne électorale dont il sortira des
faits mais simplement est ce que nicolas
sarkozy ferait mieux de 111 est ce qu
est ce qu il a raison lorsqu'il s'en
prend comme ça directement frontalement
manuel base comme le fait aussi à tj
quand nicolas sarkozy dit fn ps puisque
sa compagne
c'est pas le sujet de dire est ce qu'on
met le fn et le ps sur le même niveau
ça veut dire en vrai on comprend la
stratégie de la gauche qui est de faire
monter au maximum le fn pour essayer de
limiter les gains et les victoires de la
droite classique et le rêve secret de
françois hollande tout le monde le sait
c'est d'arriver en 2017 un fn qui serait
devant et peut-être pourquoi pas à lui
qui sera en 2 pourquoi besbes vous
savourez cette formule moi je trouve la
formule réaliste c'est à dire qu'il ya
réellement un non pas une comparaison
des partis mais des intérêts communs le
fn a intérêt à dire nous sommes les
seuls face au ps parce que comme le ps
est discrédité son a compris et le ps a
intérêt à ça parce que ça permet de dire
le voter maman la droite classique ça me
plaît parce que c'est une démonstration
de complicité électorale d'accord on va
parler du mardi on va reparler du front
national mais cette fois à l'assemblée
nationale
c'est ce que l'on appelle une joute
verbale elle a eu lieu lors des
questions d'actualité entre le premier
ministre et marion maréchal-le pen
député du front national écoutez cet
échange plutôt musclée gardez donc votre
mépris crétins et vos leçons de
république pour votre propre parti qui
en moins de trois ans a oscillé entre
phobie administratives et faux diplômes
ce n'est pas du front national que sont
issus les cas usa clé sylvie andrieux
les kader arif et tant d'autres qui ont
volé les français doit-on s'attendre
monsieur le ministre à d'autres mesures
d'exception à l'égard de notre mouvement
quand comptez-vous enfin vous occuper
des angoisses des français plutôt que du
sort de notre parti qui je l'espère se
fracassera sur les urnes à la fin du
mois je ne confonds pas madame les
électeurs du front national
je ne confonds pas les français avec
vous et je veux leur dire que vous les
tromper que vous les tromper que votre
politique mènerait le pays à la ruine en
la sortant de l'euro de la politique
agricole commune de l'union européenne
oui parce qu'il faut dire la vérité aux
français voulaient tromper vous tromper
les petites gens vous tromper les
ouvriers vous tromper les agriculteurs
vous tromper ceux qui souffrent alors il
est temps que dans ce pays il y à un
débat on déchire le voile la mascarade
est la vôtre
il est temps que nous affirmions tous
comme je lé fais ici le 13 janvier les
valeurs de la république la france mais
aussi les actes et la politique de mon
gouvernement contre la pauvreté pour
l'école pour les valeurs de la
république pour redresser le pays
c'est aussi une réponse à ce que vous
portez alors madame jusqu'au bout je
leur ai campagne pour vous stigmatisez
et pour vous dit connaître ni la
république ni la france roger karoutchi
s'est c'est chaud mais vous le trouvez
nerveux
valls oui sûrement mais je ne suis pas
de ceux qui est apprécié que dans le
cadre d'un hémicycle soit d'ailleurs
celui du sénat ou de l'assemblée ont dit
ce crétin machin les 6 es bien quelque
chose que les français ne supportent
plus c'est cette espèce de
théâtralisation absurde de la vie
publique
on peut se dire des choses on peut être
en opposition on peut être en conflit et
on n'est pas obligé d'insulter bon ça
c'est le premier point
deuxième point c'est que tout est
excessif je veux dire moi je suis de
ceux qui depuis très longtemps lutte
contre le l'action du front national et
les propositions du front national mais
chaque fois que vous en faites trop vous
avez vous obtenez l'effet inverse c'est
à dire que il faut lutter point à point
quelles sont les conséquences de la
sortie de l'europe ou de l'euro et qu'en
se réveillant riches à ne pas nous en
pensez quoi c'est la digne héritière
je trouve qu'elle est plus l'héritière
de jean marie le pen que de marine le
pen et marine le pen qui veut comment
dire notabilisé c'est peut-être beaucoup
mais rendre son parti plus présentable
et cetera
elle a un petit sujet par rapport aux
pairs et par rapport à la nièce endroits
dans les familles partout il faut ya pas
de raison qu avec et nous alors vous
déshydrater dans fête d'enfer trouvait
juste que je pense que dans votre parti
on n'en fait pas trop sur une autre
personnalité sur christiane taubira pas
dans le parti
d'abord moi j'ai déjà dit bon
sincèrement dans tous les débats coelho
c'est d'ailleurs avec madame taubira
moi je dis ce que j'ai à dire sur la
politique pénale tout porte pas de
jugement personnel parce que c'est pas
le lieu
et puis les français sont pas là pour
dire ah bah tiens t'as vu ce qu'il a dit
les gens adorent les petites phrases
sont tous voyeur très bien mais ça fait
avancer personne ni la république ni la
démocratie ni la vie quotidienne des
français ceci étant on a encore le droit
de dire que la politique pénale de
madame taubira ne nous convient pas
alors je trouve que en ce moment on va
vers deux excès 1 1 on ne peut plus rien
dire sur madame taubira
parce que s'est immédiatement traduite
une attaque personnelle
donc ça c'est excessif ont suivi le soir
oui un peu elle et d'autres pour elle si
je puis dire c'est à dire que la gauche
parlementaire ou ministériel a une
tendance à dire vous ne pouvez pas
critiquer la politique pénale parce que
ça veut dire que vous attaquez madame
taubira donc c'est un peu limite ça à
mon sens mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai
que quand je vois un des déclarations de
certains élus je ne suis pas d'accord
non plus je veux dire un ministre même
si on combat sa politique ça se respecte
et puis on essaye de faire en sorte de
gagner les élections et de faire en
sorte qu'il soit plus ministre mais
voilà je reviens de petites secondes sur
sur manuel valls parce que la première
question vous est posée savoir s'il est
un petit peu nerveux c'est revenu
beaucoup cette semaine dans la voix de
nicolas sarkozy oui mais mais c'est la
réalité moi je trouve je suis de ceux
qui disent que manuel valls a été très
bien
au mois de janvier sur un certain nombre
de sujets et que lorsqu'il défend
les valeurs de la république je ne
reconnais beaucoup dans ce qu'il dit
sauf que à un moment peut-être parce
qu'on est en période électorale
peut-être parce qu'il faut remobiliser
un homme bien divisé peut-être parce
qu'ils apprécient moyennement les
initiatives du président la république à
l'égard des frondeurs peut-être parce
qu'il sait pas trop bien s'il sera
encore là ou pas après lui dis que oui
mais il dit que oui mais vous avez déjà
vu un premier ce qu'il dit ou fait je
m'en allais est bon donc isolé de son
problème mais il ya de la nervosité et à
de l'excédent le propos est l'excès
n'arrange personne qui peut être bon
débatteur s'ils restent très calmes
on va continuer à l'assemblée nationale
ça se passe toujours mardi à l'assemblée
les députés ont voté en première lecture
la loi notre lune ou un autre c'est la
nouvelle organisation territoriale
l'examen aussi été marquée par l'abandon
des transferts des routes des
départements vers les régions les
départements qui se retrouvent conforté
avec cette loi roger karoutchi
vous y comprenez encore quelque chose
c'est une caricature j'espère bien qu on
balaiera tout ça en revenant de 2017
parce que sincèrement abrogation mais
non ce texte ni fait ni à faire
c'est le test le plus amateur que j'ai
vu en matière d'organisation des
territoires carte des régions qu'on a
eues auparavant fait sur un comptable
tiens je te mets un tel avec intel
débrouille toi tu attrapes un morceau
d'un tel autre est bien et quand la les
compétences on nous avait dit vous allez
voir la révolution de l'évolution entre
départements et régions
mais ça sur le développement économique
transfert des collèges pour l'unité
collèges lycées transfert des roues
transfert des transports colère vu au
final mais où ça n'a pas lieu mais en
revanche des trucs met à tomber par
terre
intercommunalité obligatoire dans les
zones orale au minimum vingt mille
habitants
moi je propose de nommer un
administrateur c'est ni fait ni à faire
on tue les communes on tue les communes
et d'ailleurs la mf l'association des
maires de france a fait un communiqué
commun gauche droite pour dire ce texte
est inviolable et ensuite on a reçu ce
millefeuille territorial est intouchable
mais non il est par contre je vais vous
dire par une idée concrète
par exemple dans ce texte on nous créer
une métropole du grand paris a dans la
vie à abuja on nous dit déjà il ya deux
milliards
ennemi de budget il va y avoir 1500 à
2000 agents on va chercher des immeubles
dans paris nous on avait dit au début
mais donner les pouvoirs de la métropole
à la région ne crée pas une structure
supplémentaire a ajouté dr fin on a
recréé encore un truc alors au début on
nous disait et puis alors on va tuer
lévis depuis les intercoms on va
supprimer les départements et comme ils
savent pas faire et ils ont déjà tout
perdu
il disait alors les départements on vous
avait dit qu'on est supprimée sont pas
touchés c'est très bien ça servait à
quelque chose de faire tout ce barnum
pour arriver au fait qu'on dit on touche
pas au département on n'est pas trop aux
compétences à l'ask le seul élément sur
lequel on touche beaucoup
c'est les communes rurales sacrifier et
la métropole du grand paris imposer
voilà abrogée ça veut dire quoi parce
qu'on fait ça vaut à chaque fois la
question et ça veut manger caveau sinon
je fais là dessus et grande région
mais il fallait faire 8 grandes régions
en laissant les départements avec leur
pouvoir actuel en faisant en sorte que
les gens se regroupent sur des projets
par exemple de projet ça veut dire faire
voir parce que ça veut dire
à chaque fois que quand c'est la gauche
qui est la même la gauche n'en veut pas
même la gauche ne veut pas les maires de
gauche de la mf ne veulent pas ils
disent vous tuez nos communes alors ceci
étant on n'aura pas grand chose à
abroger pas ce que je vais vous dire
j'attends de voir comment ces textes
votés en 2015 s'applique
parce que je pense que la menace à la
fin parce que les décrets d'application
votre faisable parce que les communes
rurales vendirent vous nous tuer mais
pour mettre quoi à la place vous allez
voir qu'on va mettre un an un an et demi
deux ans pour être 100 navires à quinze
jours ça ira pour vous non non non ça
n'ira pas voir et m'a pas au bout parce
que c'est contraire à l'intérêt des
habitants des zones rurales comme des
métropoles c'est contraire c'est
idéologique ses partisans et c'est
absurde
voilà ils ont voulu la métropole du
grand paris parce que quand ils ont
décidé il pensait qu'elle serait par la
gauche
alors maintenant que on a tout gagné ben
aissa plus être
alors on passe à mardi les députés cette
fois se penche sur une question sensible
celle de la fin de vie une proposition
de loi commune à l'ump et au ps et fait
un sujet sensible qui divise à droite
comme à gauche marion lefebvre becker
les malades en fin de vie pourront
dormir avant de mourir pour ne pas
souffrir et c'est l'expression de jean
leonetti l'un des deux rapporteurs du
texte les députés ont autorisé hier la
sédation profonde et continue
elle concerne les malades atteints
d'affections graves et incurables dont
le pronostic vital est engagé à court
terme dans l'opposition certains ont
réclamé une clause de conscience pour
les médecins il s'agit pas effectivement
d'avoir un médecin qui empêche le le
patient de voir sa volonté respectée il
s'agit simplement pour lui de faire
jouer sa clause de conscience et ensuite
de transmettre un autre médecin qui sera
prêt à s'engager sur cette voie sédation
profonde et continue ça me semble être
vraiment un minimum de précautions cette
clause de conscience a été rejetée
désormais les patients pourront exprimer
leur refus d'un acharnement
thérapeutique via les directives
anticipées elles auront un caractère
contraignant
c'est lui qui exprime sa volonté et à
partir d'un moule exprime sa volonté et
qu'on vérifie que les deux éléments sont
effectivement réels c'est-à-dire sa mort
est imminente et sa souffrance et pas
calmé par les traitements que l'on a mis
en place et bien ce moment là pardon de
le dire comme ça mais il a droit à ne
pas souffrir avant de mourir et pour ce
faire on le fait dormir parce qu'il ne
veut pas dire que nous supprimons comme
ça dialogue singulier qui existe entre
le médecin et le patient et sa famille
simplement nous l'encadrement les
députés ont par ailleurs refusé l'aide
active à mourir la loi n'autorise ni
l'euthanasie ni le suffit d'assister
alors voilà ce texte divise beaucoup à
droite il ya une vingtaine de députés de
droite de l'entente parlementaire pour
la famille qui estime que cette loi est
un pas vers le tas nazis
ya bernard accoyer laurent wauquiez vous
n'êtes pas sur la liste que dites vous
pour vous cette loi est un progrès
sincèrement je ne sais pas si ça va être
sur des clivages politiques
chacun réagit un peu en fonction de son
expérience personnelle familiale de ce
qu'il a vécu avec ses parents ses
grands-parents ses proches et je pense
qu'il y aura des votes plutôt sur cette
ligne là moi je sincèrement le texte est
pas encore au sénat je sais pas ce que
je ferais je ne suis pas favorable à
aller trop vite trop loin et en même
temps j'ai vu autour de moi des
souffrances qui n'en finissait plus et
je dois reconnaître que je je je vais
regarder comme ça arrivera vraiment les
propositions je pense que leonetti est
un type extrêmement humain est conscient
des réalités et s'il propose un nouveau
texte par rapport à l'ancienne loi
léonetti c'est une avancée il faut
réserver sa réponse il faut il faut est
tout à fait donc il faut je regarderai
vraiment le texte est ce que je le
voterai je n'en sais encore rien je
serais presque tenté de dire quel titre
personnel et familial
je serais assez tenté de faire en sorte
que ça avance sans aller à des excès
c'est toujours pareil le problème dans
ces cas là c'est que vous êtes toujours
pris entre l'idée de dire pourquoi
souffrir franchement quand c'est quand
vous savez que c'est au bout du bout
voilà il faut pas laisser les gens
souffrir pour rien et en même temps vous
vous dites attention n'ouvrons pas non
plus à des facilités d'accès quoi parce
que bon vous êtes faire un peu de
politique a estimé marine le pen en fin
de semaine disait que c'était une oie
électoralistes
oh non il faut pas exagérer ou alors
tout est électoraliste
dire bonjour c'est électronique
utilisation lector non je pense pas et
je pense sincèrement que même au fn il
ya sûrement des gens très partagés sur
ce texte alors ils ont fabriqué divise
la société française qui divise
forcément je pose de l'est
majoritairement elle est majoritairement
très majoritairement favorables à la
france qui bat souffrances inutiles à la
fin alors après c'est toujours très
difficile de savoir jusqu'où ça va
comment ça va il ya les autorités
religieuses et les médecins à se mêler
de ce débat enfin ils sont dans leur
rôle quand il
moi je suis un laïc positif donc j'ai
pas trop le dire mais le lay positif
reconnaît volontiers aux autorités
religieuses que quand même les autorités
religieuses sur la mort ça a du sens
qu'elle puisse s'exprimer
oui alors on change de sujet le même
jour on va parler des sociétés
d'autoroutes qui on la voulait
apparemment épargnés par l'état non le
groupe devrait en tout cas c'est dans
l'actualité le groupe de travail sur
l'avenir des autoroutes a remis son
rapport au premier ministre et
finalement résultat des courses et bien
c'est le statu quo il ya même un des
membres qui a claqué la porte de la
mission parlementaire résumé avec céline
6 au juste avant la remise du rapport il
a claqué la porte jean paul chanteguet
député ps de l'indre a démissionné du
groupe de travail sur les autoroutes
mécontent des méthodes employées par le
gouvernement dans le traitement du
dossier
une opinion partagée par la sénatrice
evelyne didier également membre du
groupe de travail qui elle a choisi de
rester on nous a mis dans des conditions
de travail qui n'était pas digne
il y avait lieu d'expliquer une position
mais pas de faire cette mascarade qui a
conduit d'une certaine façon a traité le
parlement de très mauvaises manières
au départ pourtant la feuille de route
semblait clair à partir de leurs propres
travaux
députés et sénateurs devaient faire des
propositions sur l'avenir des contrats
de concession soit les renégocier soient
les raisons
mais au final ils se sont vus remettre
un document rédigé par le gouvernement
qui ne reprend aucune de ces deux
propositions
est ce que ce groupe de travail
finalement est totalement adossée à un
découle des deux groupes parlementaires
qui avaient été mis en place ou est-ce
que ce groupe de travail est là
finalement pour donner un blanc seing à
une proposition gouvernementale
le document propose notamment de réduire
l'allongement des concessions il propose
également le dégel des tarifs qui seront
désormais basés sur des critères
écologiques
pas sûr qu'en l'état les 14
parlementaires du groupe de travail
signent le document final alors j'ai
envie de vous dire tout ça pour ça mais
j'ai quand même un souvenir que le
gouvernement était pris au piège dans ce
dossier oui c'est pas tout seul a valu
d'abord 12
c'est à dire que il lance d'abord les
déclarations absolument hallucinante
oury dans la période villepin on a
sacrifié les intérêts du pays c'était
scandaleux
on a tous concédé et c'est donc tout le
monde s'est dit voir la révolution pour
les sociétés d'autoroutes et puis au
final on voit que même des propositions
compliqué de les noyer des modérés ne
sont partenaires que le gouvernement en
réalité va imposer peu ou prou le statu
quo voilà alors est ce qui fait mal j'en
sais rien je pense qu'ils se sont rendus
compte que c'était très compliqué
juridiquement de remettre en cause les
contrats parce que il y avait par
définition des indemnités qui aurait été
lourde et on commet n'a plus un sou dans
les caisses on peut même temps que j'ai
dit tout ça oui bah voilà donc alors à
terme je pense qu'en réalité on reverra
la durée des concessions
le niveau des concessions mais bon tout
ça pour ça
mais quand il faut que monter quand même
les péages c'est les parlementaires qui
le disent les péages voulait dire le
gage autoroutier moi je suis pas
fanatique ray la berd actuel pour les
voir fava n'ont pas passé mercredi et
cette fois le sénat a décidé de se
réarmer et bien
des sanctions financières pour lutter
contre l'absentéisme des sénateurs une
nouvelle organisation du travail
parlementaire
après de nombreuses critiques le sénat a
décidé de se réformer
explications et détails de cette réforme
avec jérôme rallier certains sénateurs
parle d'une véritable révolution
le train de mesures annoncées par gérard
larcher va au moins changer les
habitudes du palais du luxembourg
travaux parlementaires financés
communication rien n'échappera aux
transformations voté ce matin par le
bureau du sénat
il faut se moderniser il faut s'adapter
et il faut répondre à notre mission et à
notre fonction à ceux qui imaginaient
qu'on allait faire de l'eau tiède
eh bien je dois dire que je nie pas que
nous faisons de l'eau chaude mais en
tous les cas ça n'est pas un mince filet
d'eau
c'est la volonté pour le sénat d'occuper
pleinement sa place sur le travail
parlementaire tout d'abord la plupart
des temps de paroles seront divisés par
deux dans l'hémicycle objectif un débat
plus concis rythmée et qui permettra de
regrouper les séances sur trois journées
du mardi au jeudi limitant l'absentéisme
en matière d'assiduité justement le
président du sénat compte frapper les
récalcitrants là où cela fait mal c'est
à dire au porte monnaie
la présence en commission au moment des
votes solennels et lors des questions au
gouvernement sera mesurée si un sénateur
est absent à plus de la moitié d'un de
ces trois critères il perdra la moitié
des 1400 euros de l'indemnité de
fonction soit 700 euros brut
et s'il manque à son devoir de présence
sur l'ensemble des critères
c'est la totalité des 1400 euros qui lui
sera retiré
ainsi que la moitié de son indemnité de
frais de mandat soit 3000 euros les
moins assidus des parlementaires de la
haute assemblée pourront donc perdre
4400 euros par mois et la sanction
s'appliquera sur trois mois enfin c'est
en matière de transparence et
d'ouverture sur l'extérieur que le
président du sénat vont révolutionner le
palet sur le site du sénat chaque
citoyen pourra retrouver le budget de
l'institution
celui des groupes politiques désormais
obligées de publier leurs comptes et la
liste de l'ensemble des collaborateurs
des sénateurs la fameuse réserve
parlementaire sera elle aussi publié
côté ouverture sur l'extérieur le sénat
veut gagner en visibilité
les
travaux en commissions souvent plus
importants que ceux dans l'hémicycle
pourront être ouverts au public voire
même diffusé et les questions
gouvernement plus médiatiques auront
lieu chaque semaine et non plus un jeudi
sur deux un ensemble de mesures
destinées à montrer que face aux
critiques de l'institution gérard
larcher ne reste pas les bras croisés
alors si vous êtes l'auteur là de l'un
des rapports qui a servi de base pour
ses annonces sur cette réforme
j'allais vous demandez révoltes ou
révolutions transformation france à la
nation c'est déjà beaucoup
devant les critiques souvent injustifiés
sur le travail du sénat il fallait
prendre des mesures des mesures qui ne
sont en rien des mesures pour
stigmatiser les sénateurs parce que on
le dit pas assez et puis on sait bien
comment font certains médias pour
dénoncer le sénat où le travail des
sénateurs en réalité beaucoup de
sénateurs travaillent beaucoup mais ils
travaillent dans leur bureau ils
reçoivent beaucoup de gens ils sont dans
des groupes d'étude d'un des groupes
d'amitié et c'est alors on le fixe que
l'hémicycle à regarder ces vides sauf
que moi je suis là du lundi au vendredi
franciliens je peux l'être là mais je
suis pas du lundi au vendredi dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'il ya des textes de
loi sincèrement je ne sais je suis pas
un spécialiste
ma présence pour faire potiche n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt si je prend pas la
parole et c'est pour faire potiche je
préfère travailler dans mon bureau aura
estimé estimé qu'avec cette rivale de
senna est sauvé je sais pas si cela est
sauvé à gauche et à droite il ya
toujours des esthètes pour dire il faut
supprimer le sénat il faut changer le
sénat est tous à gauche et à droite 1
mais le sénat a une fonction clé dans le
bicamérisme il est l'assemblée où on
raisonne travail réfléchi peut-être plus
qu'en dehors de l'émotion politique du
moment qui est plutôt l'assemblée alors
il faut pas stigmatiser le travail des
sénateurs il faut le rendre plus lisible
plus visible et et faire en sorte rire
les gens puissent travailler mais en
intervenant sur l'ailé pointe les effets
de cette réforme pour lutter contre
l'absentéisme de certains en tout cas
vous êtes là mais certains y aura des
sanctions financières
assez assez forte finalement presque à
très forte mais bon sang ça va trop loin
pour vous bah moi j'ai plus bas
partisane aussi fort j'étais sur
l'indemnité de fonction qui déjà
permettait de sanctionner pour ceux qui
auraient pas été à la moitié et vote
solennel des commissions et des
questions d'actualité j'étais sur
l'indemnité de fonction au total 3000
420 euros par mois ce qui est déjà pas
négligeable c'est beaucoup plus qu'à
l'assemblée nationale mais bon le groupe
de travail a voulu aller plus loin très
bien enfin très bien c'est comme ça ça
sanctionnera clairement les choses on a
mis sur un trimestre pourquoi parce que
parfois sur un mois imaginons vous êtes
en campagne électorale où vous avez des
problèmes personnels
vous risquez sur un mois d'un garage un
tri g un trimestre
voilà sur un trimestre salissent et ça
permet de s'organiser
on mettra sans blasco 1er octobre c'est
à dire qu'on dit à tous les élus
organisez-vous d'ici là pour faire en
sorte d'être trois jours par semaine
dans la mesure du possible à paris on
reparle des autres points mais d'abord
la propose d'écouter ce que comment
cette réforme est accueillie au sein de
l'opposition bio c'est là donc de la
gauche est cousu tout ça n'est pas née
d'aujourd'hui on l'oubli mais sous la
présidence de jean pierre bel il y avait
déjà des groupes de travail qui avait
donné un certain de direction moi même
j'avais fait un rapport sur sur
l'absentéisme
donc en fait ça fait longtemps que cette
question est posée au sénat et
aujourd'hui il répond je crois qu'il
faut saluer cette réponse nous avons
essayé de trouver un équilibre entre
l'efficacité et la rationalisation
le meilleur fonctionnement voilà c'est
comme moi je le dis souvent un bon
compromis c'est quand personne n'est
totalement content je ne suis pas
totalement content et donc je trouve que
c'est un bon compromis
alors dans cette réforme il y aura aussi
une question qui concerne la fameuse ifm
donc pour les frais de mandat enfin
l'indemnité qui permet de couvrir frais
de mandat il ya une réforme annoncée
mais il faut réformer pour cela une
ordonnance ordonnance de 1958 qu'est-ce
que quand vous allez papa tout à fait à
l'aise lol lire fm alors c'était pas le
mien groupe ça mais je crois que dans
les jours qui viennent le bureau à part
d'un certain de nos décisions sur le
niveau de l'irfm il a déjà décidé sur ce
qu'on pouvait faire de l'irfm ou ce
qu'on ne pouvait pas feu donc le temps
joue contre campagne changement de leurs
doléances de 1958 consiste à dire est ce
que on regroupe et on fiscaliste
complètement hier fm avec l'indemnité
parlementaire est ce qu'on trouve une
autre solution mais ça on ne peut le
faire que si on réforme les ordonnances
qui elle est très strict alors vous
allez à nous elle nous a découverts
devant sur cette question il faut pas
seulement le gouvernement il faut aussi
l'accord de l'assemblée nationale donc
le gouvernement n'a pas dit non ils
regardent l'assemblée nationale est un
peu plus rétives semble-t-il mais bon à
suivre il a beaucoup été question de
transparence et j'ai une question assez
précises parce qu'elle vous touche
peut-être aussi de façon personne
puisque c'est un ami patrick balkany la
semaine prochaine il doit normalement
passer devant le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale pour savoir si son immunité
parlementaire doit être levé ou pas vous
seriez aujourd'hui dans le bureau vous
demandera d'abord vous me demander
d'être député ou de sénateur est
derrière l'assemblée c'est beaucoup moi
je ne m'exprime jamais soit le problème
personnel pour noël en somme j'ai déjà
dit partout c'est que les membres du
bureau de l'assemblée vont avoir un
dossier constitué par catherine vautrin
parce qu'ils font le rapport je ne l'est
pas j'ai pas à dire oui non comme ça
parce que c'est l'air du temps je ne me
mêle jamais des problèmes que ce soit
des rats gauche ou à droite et une
justice
il ya un bureau de l'assemblée il ya un
bureau du sénat a fait son entrée un
serment on le sait c'est pas un secret
d'état
on sait bien que depuis deux ans
pratiquement
que ce soit le bureau de l'assemblée où
le bureau du sénat à ma connaissance n'a
pas rejeté des demandes de levée
d'immunité parlementaire
donc je pense que aujourd'hui quand un
juge enfin dossier sauf si le dossier
vide vous les demandes
regardez ici dans un premier temps ça a
été non pour serge dassault dans un
deuxième temps il a demandé l'avis même
il a fallu que le travail lui-même pour
ça oui
enfin il a demandé lui même il aurait il
demandé lui-même patrick balkany
peut-être gros de l'assemblée qui votent
les silures l'air assez alors vous
l'avez vue est arrivé sur ce plateau
notre partenaire du figaro pour un
décryptage de l'actuelle à l'aube du
scan jim jalce et bonjour merci d'être
avec nous comme chaque semaine et on va
commencer par parler de l'ump on va
parler un peu l'ump voilà on n'a pas
parlé encore pas encore et il ya un
débat qui monte à l'ump justement ce
moment c'est le débat sur le futur nom
du parti le parti qui va être lancée le
30 mai dit on il ya les jeux d'été qui
s'est le 30 mai c'est sur le jdd s'est
amusé interrogeait des politiques de
tous bords sur leurs propositions de
noms j'aimerais que vous réagissiez à
quelques quelques propositions alors la
première elle est plutôt consensuel
c'est celle de patrick balkany ont parlé
justement c'est le rassemblement bon
voilà plutôt consensuel vous en pensez
quoi
on l'avait proposé un certain nombre
d'ailleurs de dire le rassemblement où
deux trains moyenne de mettre le nom de
la france mais en le l'expression est
déjà bloqué donc par définition peut pas
le reprendre
et deuxièmement je pense que pour les
centristes de l'ump
ça fait un peu rpr donc c'est donc une
proposition qui va certainement beaucoup
moins vous plaire c'est celle de florian
philippot le rien pour rassemblement des
inutiles et des nantis ça vous inspire
un commentaire que tout ce qui est
excessif est vain et et florian
philippot seraient mieux inspirés de
ceux du péno front national ps également
acquis les dernières propositions du ps
lui rp pour union en recharge de projets
que leur répondez vous où
le prof c'est l'hôpital qui se fout de
la charité c'est franchement vu le
niveau zéro du ps ils sont gentils mais
eux aussi s'occupe de plus sérieusement
il ya un nom kick on entendait les
derniers ces derniers jours c'est l'airé
les républicains est-ce que vous
confirmez que ce noël est à l'étude et
qui pourrait potentiellement qu'il est à
l'étude et qui tourne je dis pas que ce
sera finalement retenu ça on verra bien
ce que le bureau politique décidera le
moment venu mais c'est vrai que les
républicains ça donne beaucoup et ça
vous plaît mais moi je suis républicain
donc ça me va bien
américain ça fait un pub oui mais il ya
eu dans en france y avait le parti
républicain qui était l'un des
fondateurs de l'udf donc le côté
centriste ou libérale de l'ump un peu ça
peut leur plaire et ses gains se
définissait souvent comme étant un
républicain il avait d'ailleurs je le
rappelle envisager de trouver un
changement et à l'époque où on avait
imaginé le changement c'était
rassemblement républicain mais elle n'a
pas le rassemblement
allez république il ya un autre mot qui
vous classe sinon moi j'aimais bien ump
mais dans la mesure où il faut changer
il faut changer absolument
je crois que si on veut élargir réformer
les statuts je participe à la commission
de réforme des statuts si vous voulez
changer complètement les statuts ouvrir
à la base et cetera
il faut aussi changer la structure et
les noms de toute façon c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui choisir un peu au final
d'ailleurs vous emmener tous de vos
relations avec nicolas sarkozy comme on
recommence vous inquiète comment ça va
non non non mais on a l'impression ces
derniers temps vous êtes un peu éloigné
lui vous avez notamment posté des
commentaires très élogieux voyez comment
vous et non mais on est pas sarkolâtres
on s'éloigne quand on est sarko l'a
attendu son avis compote façon une
phrase que sarko dit alors alors quoi
vous resterez sarko réaliste vous
définissez un parlementaire et ibo qui
définit ses positions en fonction de ses
convictions je les dis depuis un certain
temps si nicolas sarkozy tiges en
retrouvant nicolas sarkozy le nicolas
sarkozy de 2007
celui qui renverse la table celui qui va
vers des propositions révolution
r celui qui ne s'enferme pas dans des
conservatismes ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui c'est compliqué parce
que comme il veut rassembler tout le
monde au sein de la famille il s'exprime
tromper sur ce qu'il veut lui il
s'exprime plus sur ce que doit être le
mouvement moi j'attends pour le moment
je les dis clairement c'est vrai que je
me reconnais dans une certaine ligne
politique chez bruno le maire mais est
ce que cette ligne politique
correspondra à autre chose on verra
après gibert on attend de savoir ce que
je décide il n'est même pas une minute
vous valent pas les deux tweeters oui et
twitter vous vous procédez comme des
commentaires élogieux sur penaud le meur
sur le tard mais vous postez aussi des
critiques notamment à l'égard du
gouvernement n'avait pas du tout
apprécié que le gouvernement utilise
hashtag de la série politique
house of cards mais enfin ça comme ça
mais attendait qu'ils chef en gros dos
alors je voudrais bien savoir parce que
c'est mal avec avec beaucoup d'élèves
égalité oui ça plairait pas à hollande
probablement parce qu'on sait ce que ça
voudrait dire mais il peut jouer au
louis non merci jim popp du scanner et
on va passer tout de suite où plus de
l'hebdo un sujet de société un peu tabou
un peu de totem aussi les 35 heures
offre 1997 la gauche de lionel jospin
lance la réforme des 35 heures à
l'époque les négociations sont ardues
entre le gouvernement les syndicats d'un
côté et les patrons de l'autre un
documentaire de la journaliste céline
bittner nous replonge dans cette
bataille sociale et parlementer un
moment choisi par simon barbarie
elle me croit bas en 1991
et pourtant six ans plus tard martine
aubry deviendra la dame des 35 heures
la raison est politique un gage du
gouvernement jospin à la gauche
plurielle
effectivement dans les engagements qui
avaient été pris par rapport aux as et à
ses différents partenaires
il y avait les 35 heures et les 35
heures sous forme de loi donc
politiquement à la marge de manoeuvre de
lionel jospin des très faibles
le documentaire les 35 heures la
fracture réalisé par la journaliste
céline bittner associe images d'archivés
et témoignages de soutien et opposants à
la réforme qui chacun campe toujours sur
ses positions
tous rendent hommage au formidable sens
politique de martine aubry
certains l'ont peut-être brocardé mais
beaucoup l'ont admiré et tout le monde
au bout du compte effectivement bien
fait le job
la bataille fut sociale et législatives
mais c'est sur le terrain de l'opinion
qu'elle s'est finalement gagné - vous
travaillez plus vous rendez service à la
collectivité aurait dix ans le chômage
elle est extrêmement difficile si vous
voulez de trouvé l'argumentaire
économique simple pour contrer quelque
chose aussi souriant les 35 heures
progrès social ou symbole du déclin
économique français quinze ans plus tard
le débat est toujours d'actualité
le débat est toujours d'actualité cette
loi semble bien installé dans le paysage
social français elle le restera
non non nicolas sarkozy voyait que pure
fm a parfaitement raison c'est 20 ans
d'un échec
elle était faite théoriquement
l'entendre d'air pour dire ça va réduire
le chômage
donc dire on peut pas dire s'est
inversée comme dirait françois hollande
la courbe du chômage
on est au maximum le chômage continue
d'évoluer d'augmenter ça veut dire que
les 35 heures ont raté leurs objectifs
si c'était de répandre le travail de
permettre l'intégration de plus de monde
dans le monde du travail a échoué mais
personne n'a le courage d'aimer ça et
jouer alors si pendant le mandat de
nicolas sarkozy
décidément on a assoupli les conditions
permis des accords d'entreprise etc
est ce que il faut aller plus loin
nicolas sarkozy sur la ligne de dire le
la situation permettrait de dire il ya
plus d'obligations c'est à dire que
chaque entreprise déciderai d'autres
disent non il faut passer de manière un
peu en deçà des halles de 35 heures à 37
heures ou à 39 heures au programme le 10
ans hervé morin ou ou françois fillon et
vous vous dites quoi moi je pense que
soit celle à moi je ne sais plus sur la
ligne de sarko là dessus parce que je
trouve que les règles qu'on impose à
tout le monde dans tout le pays de
manière uniforme
ça n'a pas de sens autant je dis qu
évidemment pour la fonction publique
faudra par une décision horaires parce
que là ça s'appliquera pour tous autant
et notamment à l'hôpital et autant dans
les entreprises il peut y avoir des
accords d'entreprise vous voyez vous
êtes proche de nicolas sarkozy
mais je les ai toujours été et est allé
il ya quand même des chances que les
choses dures mais au-delà de ça je vous
retrouvez le boss merci beaucoup roger
karoutchi d'avoir laissé sur le plateau
de par le monde où on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine bonne semaine à tous